what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we're picking up with Jonathan
Hickman's ultimate to the ultimate
Avengers from the ultimate universes of
course this is before Secret Wars 2015
so normally we wouldn't cover this but
we're gonna go back through and we're
gonna like well I guess we're gonna
continue remastering Jonathan Hickman
Avengers the New Avengers now that were
getting like closer to the release of
Avengers 4 and because of that we kind
of have to cover that so the reason why
is because what this does is it sets the
stage for what goes on with regards to
like the Ultimate Universe during the
events of the collapse of the multiverse
which is to say like once you get into
like the immediate lead-up to Secret
Wars 2015 now the idea behind this is
this kind of an important thing this
comes out of the events of ultimatum and
ultimate fallout ultimatum of course was
a story we covered where like you learn
the origin of mutants in the Ultimate
Universe and Magneto like floods the
world and different things like that but
ultimate fallout was kind of the big
thing that this came out of an ultimate
fallout was kind of Marvel's way of sort
of reshuffling the ultimate universe yet
again right because like in 2000 the
ultimate universe was launched it was
really really popular for some number of
years and then just by virtue of what
was really just kind of poor riding on a
lot of the titles outside of spider-man
it just kind of began to flounder and so
then once you got into like the
mid-2000s doing in 2011 Marvel kind of
rework the whole thing and so we're
Altima tall out basically dealt with the
aftermath of the death of ultimate
spider-man what Marvel did is they they
kind of reworked Fantastic Four they
reworked x-man they reworked the
ultimate in order to kind of push
forward with the stories and so what
this does is this initially picks up
with a guy that we only know as the
maker now for those of you guys who are
familiar with him please do not spoil it
down below but it is kind of a cool
concept here because what he's done here
is formed something called the children
of tomorrow now we will get an
explanation on what that is here in a
second but for right now just kind of
let that sit in the back of your heads
but what's happened is the maker has
formed something called the city and
it's just like this giant Citadel that
it sort of exists out there in northern
Germany and so again nobody really
considers it to be much of a threat
because it's just kind of a thing that's
there and no one really knows about it
and so what it does is it shifts over to
shield proper now when it comes to the
ultimate universe in Marvel Comics this
is what the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
based off of and the reason why I say
this was because it will run because it
is based off of it and to because of the
fact that the Ultimate Universe was
designed to be more grounded what would
it look like if Marvel Comics characters
as we knew them existed in the real
world
and so what's going on here is there are
like a handful of incident which are
being monitored by shield in the
Ultimate Universe shield had a
more hands-on approach than they did in
the main Marvel Universe with regards to
like how they dealt with conflicts and
monitoring everything and all that kind
of good stuff and of course they're
based off the out of the Triskelion
which you guys are recognized from the
MCU from Captain America the Winter
Soldier but what's happened here is that
the EDI the European Defense Initiative
is responding to what's basically kind
of craziness going on in Asgard there's
a couple things that we have to explain
here when it comes to Asgard in the
Ultimate Universe all we really knew
about it was the old Thor comics in in
or I guess the old ultimate Thor comics
which is to say like Asgard was a
mythological place that existed at some
point along one and then eventually four
was cast out of Asgard and he was sent
to earth now at the time Marvel kind of
toyed with the idea on whether Thor was
actually Thor or if he was just a crazy
guy who believed he was four and for a
long time we didn't really know
eventually mod will clear that up and
said he has actually Odin son reborn in
human form but at the time Asgard was
essentially destroyed now all that
really kind of coalescing came together
when Asgard was recreated after the
return of Odin and then it was sent to
earth so it's very similar with regards
to like the aftermath of civil war in
the main Marvel Universe when Odin
returns to life and then resurrects
Asgard I guess really returns as guarded
like Broxton Oklahoma the difference
here is that the Asgardians are very
just like wild folk is really what they
are they party in and they get into all
kinds of crazy things but the European
Defense Initiative is basically Europe's
version of like The Ultimates but the
European Defense Initiative is
responding of course to everything going
on in Asgard and Thor is sent by Nick
Fury to go check everything out as well
the problem with this is that at the
same time this is all going on there's
Ironman responding to a threat so again
there's a lot of different things
happening in the world as it stands now
now a lot of this again coming out of
ultimatum the fact that the world was
almost destroyed really led to like a
heightened sense of security
now when the EDI shows up to Asgard in
order to kind of be like you guys got to
calm down stop being so rowdy stop being
so crazy
Thor actually offers Jimmy Braddock a
drink and when Jimmy Braddock pours it
out
then his nick fury's watching all this
unfold he's like okay so things are
about to pop off and they do you end up
having like this massive fight that
breaks out between the European defense
initiative and the Asgardians at the
same time that's going on you've got
Ironman responding to what's basically a
ghost ship on like a collision course
and Ironman of course is responding and
trying to get it all sorted out trying
to figure out what's going on the issue
with this is that when he gets on board
that ship and as he's going through and
investigating it when he tries to take
it down he ends up realizing the ship
has a nuclear bomb on board
thermal nuclear device which detonates
and and seemingly seems to kill Iron Man
in the process now of course this is a
drone that he has out there but remember
he's mentally linked to it so it's one
of those things were it's like Iron Man
Thor I guess Tony Stark through a mental
link is kind of blown up by a by a
nuclear device now with Jamie Braddock
and with Thor and the other members of
the EDI basically Captain Britain
Captain Italy Captain France with them
responding to what this this giant city
that's sitting out there they're
immediately yanked in you know and then
from there it's just kind of like okay
what do we do because what's going on
here is that all signals have
essentially been lost where you have
like all these different events that are
going on that are being monitored by
shield at the same time they all go down
and so shield is essentially flying
blind they have no idea what's going on
in all these various missions that they
have taking place all across the world
and so what we end up doing is kind of
shifting back for a second and focusing
on the nature of this city now this city
houses a group called the children of
tomorrow and the idea is that inside the
city once the walls went up that
basically time started passing at an
accelerated rate well we're not really
given like a timeframe here what we're
told is that 900 years have basically
passed inside this city and so initially
it started out as people who were just
trying to look to make the world a
better place or at least that was the
auspices they are operating under as
time began to progress and as they began
to evolve they began to shift away from
traditional means of procreation and
started like evolving people sort of
creating human beings as that began to
progress
suddenly name started to go away it's
not being like Emma the fourth it's not
being John the third it started turning
into things like like the sword the
knife names began to go away and they
started achieving this kind of hyper
accelerated rate of evolution becoming a
much better version of themselves now
while all that was going on they started
achieving higher levels of Technology a
better understanding of like the human
genome basically kind of becoming like
perfect beings but again like like while
that's going on because I took such a
short amount of time to happen when
Jimmy Braddock and company are pulled
inside the city they're met with these
hyper evolved beings and as they go
through and start analyzing Jimmy
Braddock and all them they start
determining their weaknesses things that
are wrong with them so on and so forth
and trying to find a way to kind of
perfect them quote-unquote and so with
that what that happening again it's
really kind of like pandemonium and it's
panic and is trying to figure out what's
going on so of course for basically kind
of breaks into the whole place or at
least seems to break in they start
analyzing him and then really come to
the conclusion that he's basically like
a god of swords now of course I a man
also recovers from this thermal nuclear
device albeit his mind is totally addled
and in return actually Don
the Ironman suit and then goes to work
Nick where Nick Fury tells him to which
is exactly where the city is and so it's
kind of all the Ultimates descending on
this one particular area now what we
actually end up doing here is kind of
picking up with the maker and picking up
with city proper and what I mean by that
is that where this was just a giant dome
that was allowed to kind of evolve on
its own what I did is it evolved in
basically an artificial intelligence
now the artificial intelligence does
function according to the whims and
wants of the maker but it is capable of
functioning independently the difference
here is that the maker is kind of like
the god of the city itself and so where
Thor is being analyzed by by one of the
researchers one of the scientists and
they don't really know what Thor is the
maker looks on it and says I know
exactly who that is that's Thor he's a
legitimate God he's an Asgardian we have
to find a way to basically you know
access him or capture him or figure out
what we can do here and so when is up
happening is the researcher within the
city begins to look at Odin's son and
realize that he's not just powerful in
and of himself that he's actually
channeling energy energy coming from
Odin and energy coming from the tree of
a Drusilla and so the response is we can
drain those sources of energy and we can
enhance ourselves and so they
immediately take to Asgard proper with
the intention of attacking the place
while the Asgardians aren't you know do
have heightened abilities and so on and
so forth they're also destroyed by the
various you know various children who
were here they of course access Odin
they begin draining Odin of his own
energy as life force essentially the
odinforce at the same time like they
drain the tree of Idris loved all its
energy and what this does is it leaves
Thor powerless he's got no abilities
whatsoever now this is where things
really kind of kind of require a bit of
an explanation here because of the fact
that Odin's son when he originally
appeared in the alternate universe
because Odin was basically dead because
Asgard was destroyed he had no real
source of energy instead what he got was
this kind of bioenhanced suit that was
given to him by the EDI which in turn he
would use to function as for and that's
why you saw him with like the the six
lights on his chest Anna and a hammer
that basically looked like looked like
Stormbreaker to a degree that beta ray
bill uses once Asgard came back and once
Odin came back then we got the ultimate
universe version of Thor as we knew him
not with Thor basically being powerless
what Iron Man had done was bring back
the old force suit from the beginning of
the Ultimate Universe and then modify it
with a new set of abilities one of which
will actually see later on here in in
this story but with that happening Thor
does kind of read ons the outfit and
then in turn goes forward the issue with
this is that this city as it exists has
actually been expanding by one kilometer
per hour and is basically
kind of spread all throughout a lot of
the northern northern German area city
after City after city and territory
after territory is basically being
conquered by the city and being being
taken over in its entirety in response
to this you have shield that basically
launches an attack against the city and
nothing works not only does nothing
worked the city launches his own
defenses and actually starts crushing
shield it's essentially the end times
but then you have Nick Fury who calls
for the use of nuclear weapons now this
is kind of designed to show us how
desperate things are the use of nukes in
really even within the confines of the
Ultimate Universe as grounded as it is
is one of those things where the end
times were upon us because you're
talking about obliterating the entirety
of a city and then an uninhabitable area
that surrounds it they carrying a
radiation and the idea that for some
period of time no one could live there
until the radiation basically disperses
how long that would be we don't fully
know the issue at this is that when the
nukes are launched they're immediately
contained by the by the children of
tomorrow they're literally prepared for
it as it was kind of a crazy scenario
because what Nick Fury is required to do
is basically sound the general retreat
the problem with this is they cannot get
out in time the forces of the children
of tomorrow are about to usurp them and
so that's when one of the powers of
Thor's new suit manifests when he
basically teleports them all away the
problem with this is that for Thor the
destruction of Asgard came from the
children of tomorrow and it's a personal
vendetta is really all this is and so in
this moment he basically tells Iron Man
you're a great warrior you're a great
friend that kind of thing and then
teleports away and it's kind of a crazy
scenario because it's almost kind of
fast tracking the relationship between
Thor and various other characters and
that's one of the things I want you guys
to keep in the back of your head is
because when it comes to Jonathan
Hickman writing styles what he does is
he focuses a lot on care to development
but he does it in a reasonable way now
with this with Ultimates he's kind of
kind of building on what's already been
there is one of those interesting little
scenarios here and so with Thor
basically teleporting away arriving in
the city proper when he gets there the
AI realizes Thor is there but instead of
like obliterating him in his entirety
they kind of allow him to enter is
really kind of seeing like I wonder
what's gonna happen here now this is
kind of a funny scenario because what
this does is it shows how hopelessly
outmatched Thor is if the maker and and
the AI were legitimately concerned that
Thor could actually destroy the entire
city itself they wouldn't have let him
in but the fact that they let him in
shows that Thor is no real credible
threat to them they'll keep him on Thor
is vastly depowered right now in
relation to how he was when he had his
hammer he was channeled by the power of
Odin and the
he'll treat so again he's a much weaker
version of himself but when he gets in
there he ends up meeting with a
researcher of sorts or at least a nurse
who's kind of helping these kids you
know helping to grow these children here
and and so on and so forth again she
refers to herself as a force the fourth
nurse so she doesn't actually have a
name that's really all it is like Thor
gets here she's like well the people
you're looking for that way so head over
that direction and of course she sends
him over to Jamie he ends up freeing
Jamie and that's when he's met with the
maker and it's kind of a big thing here
because in this moment what is up
happening is the maker basically sits
down and starts talking to Thor anything
basically says look like you have a
mission here like like you're here for a
goal that's fine but like you're not
gonna win and when the questions asked
why the maker says first knife show him
out hopelessly outmatched he is and the
first knife literally runs circles
around Thor I mean overpowers him in
every way mother time Thor has thrown
like one shot the knife has hit him like
three or four times so it's like there's
no real competition here for Thor Thor
swings once and in the time it takes for
him to do a 180 degree rotation of his
hammer like he's essentially defeated
just kind of falls to the ground and
that's the end of that and the maker
keeps telling the knife just keep
punishing him just keep punishing him
until he realizes what's going on and so
the maker likes like literally tells
Thor like I want you to know who I am
he shows Thor his face and then he says
your message is to go forward tell
shield tell humanity their time is up
what I've done is I've built a city that
will expand out it stopped expanding for
right now I'm giving you guys a general
chance to come to terms with what's
going to happen to your world but once
we begin expanding there's nothing gonna
be able to do to stop us and we're
essentially going to end all things like
we're going to take over the entirety of
the world we're going to eliminate
humanity in its quote-unquote impure
form right now and we're in turn gonna
replace it with something better and
that's kind of the crazy thing is
because with all this going on Thor is
forced to accept the fact that he's that
outmatched
one soldier from the city was enough to
totally overpower Thor what happens when
like the entire forces of the city are
sent forward that's the other thing is
because you're talking about the city of
self expanding outward when Jamie
Braddock was captured what that did is
it revealed that not only are they
growing children at a hyper accelerated
rate what they're also doing is they're
taking those individuals who were
captured and they're modifying their
genetic material they're perfecting them
and so what they get what they're
basically doing is taking and taking an
army or making an army out of those
who've been conquered and turning them
into soldiers and then they're gonna
send them forward so literally it's a
it's a weapon manufacturing Citadel this
is onda to literally conquer earth and
so not only that Thor
to grips with like the full totality of
what it means with the city's denizens
when he sits down any talks and Nick
Fury tells Nick Fury everything that
happened in Nick ass is there anything
else and Thor responds by saying yes
there's one more thing the person who's
leading this city the maker himself is
Reed Richards and that's the crazy thing
here is because we basically know
finding out this is ultimate Reid now
this is what we start getting into an
explanation on what's what's been going
on here and how Reid got to this point
so the way this played out was when the
ultimate Fantastic Four first popped up
it was just a retelling of the Fantastic
Four and that was really it all that
came to a head during the events of
ultimatum and the events of ultimate
fallout and some of the stories that
came after and the way this played out
was that when Susan storm was
potentially going to die that Reed
Richards chose to protect the world
instead of her and what this did is it
created a rift between the two and Susan
storm turned her back on Reed and so
where the idea behind that was that Reed
was going to be written out he was
basing gonna be eliminated Jonathan
Hickman used that as a means to bring
him back and to basically say that Reed
is now essentially a villain and he's on
like a mission to basically perfect the
world by eliminating humanity in its
impure form and then in turn trying to
create a purified version of itself
especially regis kind of become a
narcissist and a megalomaniac by
believing he's the perfect being and
trying to remake everybody in his image
it's pretty awesome well that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]